okay quick example typical kind of
arrangements type question okay how many
trifectas are there by how many ways are
there of getting a trifecta right in a
race of Surrey of who usually has like
eight lanes right so four eights from
this you know who might have to say had
their legs recently shaved for extra
speed okay how many different trifectas
are there that we can get okay now how
we usually work this out anyone how much
detail you wanna put in you could have a
box of three different slots trifectas
per second day right and you would say
for the first slot there are a
consumer's so how many possibilities are
there
Hey and then for the next one
it's 8 minus 1 because you've lost 1 & 7
& 6
okay so your actual number of ways is H
by 706 okay now a more concise way of
writing that like whether these numbers
actually come from is see how it's it's
reducing by what every time so that's
actually built off K factorial okay but
in order to eliminate all these terms
off the end that's five factorial right
I'm dividing by 5 factorial okay where's
the 5 come from the 5 comes from Kenny
what's it yeah it's a it's this - this
right it's how many I actually want out
of the total group so this is really 8
minus 3
okay now this is we have notation for
this right and since your calculator
which ones this this is 8
what
is it PLC it's a GUI see hands up to
vote for C see ya okay sir hands up a P
come on commit did you know you people
okay
one two three four five six seven seven
people got it right that's a it is P
okay it is P right because it's
permutations and combinations right so
the way I think about it is permutations
small starts now together combinations
you can combine things just throw them
again in a pile it doesn't matter which
ones which just saw the question is
which ones do you have right whereas
eight people tations
right is which ones pursuit for a second
totally matters right captain vice
captain there will be tears over who's
in that spot so AP three okay all right
now let's go back to the situation were
thinking your office what if all I'm
interested in is just the top three
centers okay so I'm still we still
getting this trifecta thing right but
I'm now forgetting about order okay well
I can think about it in much the same
way and curve through the same process
okay with one difference okay which one
has more ways this one or this one which
one's gonna give you a bigger number
he's gonna give me a bigger number right
because suppose the top three were um
you know
let's see because to me James and it's a
boys race okay so now this this this top
three right this top three as a trifecta
is different as a trifecta from this
just cuz you like
it's like that you know something's
gonna come through okay don't worry
Italy's people came for fifty six and
seven eight so now those are different
track vectors right but they are the
same top three Sooners okay so going
from this question to this question if
my answer was just a p3 okay whatever
that number is I've ever counted right
I'm over counted so the number of ways
here has to be less than eight p3 it's
got to be divided by something what am I
going to divide by to fix up my over
counting I'm going to divide by three
factorial right can anyone see why why
is it three factorial
good exactly right these these are here
right if you think about it as look
these are the same and I could do I
could do more than that right
whatever six six combinations okay
they're different trifectas but they're
all the same here and every time you get
a different combination I'm gonna get
six times as many they're all the same
to me cuz I'm just interested in top
three okay so to write this properly out
in factorial notation okay and it's
really important that you get used to
remembering what what these actually
mean and you know the form is cuz you be
asked to proof stuff with the minimum
this is really three factorial and this
is what we call a Jew's three okay
all right now that was your a vision
okay
but here's where I'm gonna try and make
my leap so get your thinking hat on for
this one this is the really tricky bit
okay
keep this in your back of your mind and
let's think about ways arranging let's
think about letters now okay so suppose
you wanted to rearrange the name Jeff
Lee okay right so actually pick the same
specific purpose how many ways are there
to arrange this name okay well there are
six total letters so I'm going to start
with six factorial but in just the same
way as from here to here I
or we counted haveno I've overcome it by
a factor of two factorial which which
happens to also be - okay so I really
should do that right so this two
factorial here accounts for the
repetitions right which just like over
here this 3 factorial accounts for the
fact that these are kind of repetition
so it's the same setup yeah all right
take a different name like say this know
how many letters nine okay but here I've
got more than just one double up right
I've got here's my other color I've got
two S's and I've got two A's yes okay so
really I'm not just gonna divide that
two factorial
I'm gonna divide by two factorial
factorial okay so I'm doing this every
time I've got a repeat yes
alright now the special case the most
useful case for us getting towards this
topic okay is what if I think about
words made up of letters that there are
just two different kinds right so my my
son read this book and there's a
character called baa baa the Sheep okay
so how many ways on it of arranging
these letters well in just the same way
total number of letters is and then I
have to divide by it okay well how many
repeats are okay to B's and for it okay
now remember I told you before right
that I'm thinking now of words that just
have two kinds of letters right so where
is this - in this - here are quite
independent they come from two different
things this - and this for are not
independent right because as soon as I
know there are two of one kind of letter
because I've just told you there are
only two kinds of letters here there
must be four of the other one right so I
could write this in three different ways
I could write this as 6 factorial on 2
factorial now where is the four come
from it's however many are left right
namely
- two factorial that makes sense
likewise I could think about from the
other point of view I could say it's six
factorial on think about the other
repeater that before
all right and then how many will be left
6 - 4 factorial okay so these are really
the same they're both the same right now
look at what we just did you okay can
you see that this problem of thinking
about you know just two kinds of letters
and arranging that right is really
getting at the same notation we're
talking about earlier right
this is six choose two right and this is
6 choose 4 both of which are equal okay
hmm so far so good